so far with such incredible inspiration
and there is Magnus Carson and the
handshake
classic classic Magnus it comes one
second before the start of the round
he's got his victuals yeah he's got his
hydration his H2O there
and uh pragnanada will have the white
pieces in the first game which puts a
special kind of pressure on you this is
a two-game match in the old days the
World Cup final was four games and all
smiles there from I think from only one
player proc seems sufficiently relaxed I
think he's having a great time and will
he be having a great time in this game
he sticks with one C4 the ceremonial
first move corresponded to prague's
actual choice
here we go yes yeah this be actually
should come as a slight surprise to
Magnus Prague has been playing a lot of
E4 D force in the tournament yeah he did
play C4 as well but certainly you
wouldn't be thinking about Prague